الى تطورات في روسيا حيث قال الرئيس
بلاديمير بوتين ان تمويل مجموعه فاغنن كان
يقع على عاتق الحكومه الروسيه وخصوصا
وزاره الدفاع واشار الى ان تمويل فاجنر
كلف ميزانيه الدوله ما يعادل مليارا ومئه
مليون دولار في عام واحد كما شكر بوتين في
خطاب له الاجهزه الامنيه وقال ان التدابير
التي اتخذت حاله دون وقوع حرب اهليه حول
كل هذه التصريحات تنضم الينا من موسكو
مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي وسنبدا معك
رانيا بالتصريحات التي صدرت عن الرئيس
البيلاروسي قبل قليل حول قائد فاجنر
بالفعل هو الخبر الاول لان صح التعبير
يعني تم التاكيد رسميا من قبل الرئيس
البيضاء الروسيه قبل قليل على وصول مالك
شركه فاغنر
الى الاراضي البيلاروسيه ولكن الاهم من
ذلك السم تبعهم من تصريحات من قبل الرئيس
الكسنكا عندما قال انه يوافق وزير الدفاعه
عندما قال انه ان القوات البيلاروسيه
بحاجه لوحدات مثل قوات فاجنر اي يمكن
القول بعباره اخرى ان هذه القوات قوات فار
التي تنسحب من الاراضي الروسيه نحو
الاراضي البيلاروسيه ستخدم الى جانب صفوف
القوات المسلحه البيلاروسيه كل ذلك يتزامن
وهذه وهذا مؤشر ايضا في غايه الاهميه مع
اتمام او التوجه نحو اتمام نشر الاسلحه
التكتيكيه النوويه الروسيه على الارض في
بيلاروسيا وعليه يمكن الحديث انه في ظل كل
هذه التطورات
الجانب البيلاروسي يعمل على تعزيز ليس فقط
على قدراته النوويه الاستراتيجيه وحسب بل
وايضا على تعزيز قدرات قواته القتاليه
بانضمام مجموعه فاقنر
للاراضي البيلاروسيه وبالتالي الى القوات
المسلحه البيلاروسيه بشكل عام لابد من
الاشاره ال سي ان اليوم الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين كان قد تناول مساله التمرد المسلح
وقوات فاجنر في تصريحات عديده ولكن ابرزها
هو ما تحدث به عن عدم انضمام الشعب الروسي
والقوات المسلحه الى صفوف ما سماهم
بالمتمردين اشار الرئيس الروسي ان القوات
المسلحه الروسيه في هذا الوقت الذي وصفه
بالصعب
واجهه المتمردين وان تصرفاتها التي وصفها
بالدقيقه والسريعه حاله دون وقوع حرب
اهليه وهو سيناريو الاخطر حسب تعبيره وسفك
الدماء الروسيه نقطه اخرى في غايه الاهميه
اسيا وهي يمكن القول السابقه من نوعها
لاول مره السلطات الروسيه رئيس روسي
فواديمير بوتين تحدث عن ان شركه فاجنرك
يتم تمويلها بشكل كامل من ميزانيه الدوله
من ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع حيث اشار بوتين
الى انه خلال عام واحد انطلاقا من شهر
مايو من العام الماضي حتى شهر مايو من
العام الجاري تم انفاق اكثر من 86 مليار
دولار
مليار روبل عفوا اي ما يعادل نحو مليار
ومئه مليون دولار تم تمويل شركه باغينر
بهذه الاموال التي ذهبت كمحفزات ماليه
ورواتب لمقاتلي فاكتور لنسمع لما قاله
بوتين في هذه الجزئيه
فضلا عن ذلك لابد من الاشاره وهي المره
الاولى التي تتحدث بها روسيا في يعني عن
تدخل خارجي في هذا التمرد المسلح منذ
الرابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر حيث اعلن
رئيس حرس الوطني حرس الوطني الروسي عن ان
معرفه الدول الغربيه معرفه الاستخبارات
الغربيه يعني منذ اسابيع بهذا التمرد
بالتخطيط لهذا التمرد يدل على انها كانت
قد شاركت في التحضير له والاشراف عليه ولم
يستبعد ايضا امكانيه ان تكون قد شاركت فيه
على الارض شاركت في هذا التمرد المسلح
بشكل عام اشاره يعني رئيس الحرس الوطني ان
اي تحرك كان نحو نحو العاصمه موسكو كان
سيتم قمعه هدوء يعني لا محال ولكن اشار
ايضا الى اتخاذ قرارات في غايه الاهميه
وهي تسليح الحرس الوطني على خلفيه هذه
الاحداث بالاسلحه الثقيله والدبابات وهنا
لابد من الاشاره للحرس الوطني الروسي لا
يتمتع بهذه القدرات ولكن في ظل هذه
التطورات الاخيره بالفعل تم اتخاذ هذا
القرار السيا شكرا جزيلا لك يا رانيا
دريدي مراسلتنا في موسكو